بعد قرابه عام ونصف من القتال باتت القوات
الروسيه تسيطر على قرابه 14% من مساحه
اوكرانيا السيطره الروسيه الان متمركزه في
الشريط الجنوبي الشرقي من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بين عملياتك الرنوفر وسيطره
واستعاده السيطره يثبت شكل الخريطه هناك
لكن منذ اسابيع والحديث يتردد عن هجوم
اوكراني مضاد يقول الرئيس الروسي ان
اوكرانيا بدات هذا الهجوم لكنها لم تحقق
ايا من اهدافه منذ ايام تؤكد كييف انها لم
تبدا بعد هذا هجوم فيه كثير كلام عن الدعم
الغربي تلك دول لا تؤيد ان تنفذ القوات
الاوكرانيه هجمات داخل العنق الروسي وبناء
على التحفظ الغربي هذا تؤكد اوكرانيا ان
ضرباتها في الاراضي الروسيه لم ولن تنفذ
باسلحه غربيه الهدف هو ان داعمي اوكرانيا
لا يريدون الدخول في مواجهه مباشره مع
في الميدان تتجه الانظار الى لوغانس
كودونيتس وخيرسون وفي العمق القرن شبه
الجزيره التي تسيطر عليها روسيا منذ 2014
تؤكد اوكرانيا انها لم ولن تتنازل عنها
لكن ماذا سيستهدف الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
منذ اشهر قليله تتعرض مقاطعات روسيا على
الحدود مع اوكرانيا الى هجمات حدود تمتد
الى قربه 2200 كم تتوزع الهجمات على هذا
الشريط الطويل بين صواريخها ومسيرات قادمه
من اوكرانيا او مقاتلين على الارض هناك
مناهضين لموسكو تدعمهم كيف ينفذون عمليات
ضد الجنود الروس لم تعد بالجرود الروسيه
وحدها التي تتعرض لتلك الهجمات ما وراء
تدخل مقاطعه فورونيج في دائره الاستهداف
هكذا تصبح مقاطعه الحدود الجنوبيه الغربيه
من روسيا في دائره النار تلك مقاطعه تزيد
مساحتها على 1200 كم
ذلك رقم لا يكاد يذكر من مساحه روسيا الا
ان الخاصره الجنوبيه الغربيه من البلاد لا
تبدو مستقره كما كان عليه الحال قبل
فبراير من العام الماضي تلك خاصره لا تبعد
كثيرا عن العاصمه موسكو التي تعرضت لهجمات
سابقا لم تتبنها اوكرانيا هكذا تسير الحرب
تتحرك خريطه المشهد الميداني الان بعد ان
كانت الاعين والحسابات العسكريه محدوده في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه اصبح العمق الروسي
داخل دائره التوتر المتصاعد فاي صيف سيكون
على طرفي الحدود الروسيه الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]